-We don't always have
enough time
to cover everything
in the recent news,
so here with a recap is one of
our writers, Amber Ruffin,
in a segment we call
"Amber Says What."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You guys!
Things have been crazy.
Okay.
First of all, Nike came out
with a Colin Kaepernick ad,
and everyone was like, "What?"
Only some people were like,
"What?"
And some people were like,
And I was like, "What, what?"
Then Nike ran that ad
during Thursday Night Football,
and I was like
[Laughing] "Oh, what?!"
It was such a kick in the nuts
to racists,
they're gonna have to take
a knee.
[ Laughter ]
Then -- Then Aretha Franklin's
funeral happened,
and it was amazing.
First, and this is true,
Aretha had
four different outfit changes
at her own funeral!
I was like, "What?!"
Then, more than 100
pink Cadillacs
escorted her hearse
into the funeral,
and I was like, "What?"
Then, Fantasia sang,
And then she took her shoes off,
and I was like, "What?"
[ Laughter ]
Then I looked down,
and she had sung my shoes off,
and I was like, "Well, what?"
Then, they were like,
"Next up is Faith Hill,"
and I was like,
"Yay, Faith Hill!"
And then she came on,
and I was like, "What?"
That's when I learned Faith Hill
is not Faith Evans,
and in my mind,
they were both Faith Evans,
and now I understand
why Faith Evans
won best country album --
because she did not.
[ Laughter ]
Then, after Ariana Grande sang,
some creepy pastor grabbed
some serious side boob,
and I was like, "What...
do you think you're doing?"
Do you think we cannot see you?"
Then he made a joke about her
name being off a Taco Bell menu,
and I was like, "What...
has happened to your brain?
Did the energy from her boob
suck the common sense
out of your head?"
Oh, it made me so mad!
I was like, "What?"
Then, I saw some big,
fancy bunch of fabric,
and I was like,
"Ooh! What's this?"
And I looked under it
and found Cicely Tyson,
and I was like, "What?"
She looked so perfect,
I could not handle it.
Then, two days later,
the funeral was over.
Then, Fox News posted a story
trying to shame
actor Geoffrey Owens
for working at a Trader Joe's,
and I was like, "What?"
I didn't know you could
be shamed for having a job.
Just because he was on a sitcom
does not mean he's rich.
People on TV don't make
what you think.
Seth asked me to borrow $10
this morning.
-What?
I did not!
-Then,
something insane happened --
the president
of the French Tennis Federation
said Serena's French Open
catsuit went too far,
and I was like, "Quoi?"
[ Laughter ]
In a sport where this, this,
and this
are regular things to wear,
this is too far?
Maybe the thing you have
a problem with is her body.
And I know a lot of people
aren't ready to hear this part,
but when you're skinny,
people let you live.
But when you're a curvaceous
black woman,
people feel like it's okay
to tell you to cover up.
I tell you what.
-Whoo!
-Goddamn right, "Whoo!"
[ Laughter ]
I tell you what,
if I had Serena's body,
you couldn't get no clothes
on me.
I'd be too beautiful
and too fast!
[ Cheers and applause]
Aah!
Then, during Saturday's
championship,
things got crazy.
For the first time in history,
a tennis player got frustrated.
[ Laughter ]
And it warranted
a loss of a point,
a loss of a game,
and a racist cartoon.
I saw that and was like,
"What else is new?"
And I know a lot of you aren't
ready to hear this, but...
when you're a white man,
your whole tennis career
can be about tantrums.
But when you're a black woman,
that same behavior
will cost you dearly.
Afterwards, in an interview,
Serena said...
That's class!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Ser -- Ooh!
Yeah!
I love her. I love her.
I love her so bad.
Serena Williams makes me want
to be a better person,
but not right now
because now,
some tennis umpires
are reportedly thinking
about boycotting Serena's games.
Well, guess what?
Tennis doesn't belong to you,
you raggedy pieces of [bleep]
It's not her fault
she dominates a sport
you so desperately want
to keep white!
She's excellent!
Too [bleep] bad!
And it's the referee's fault she
yelled, not hers!
Asking her to shut up
and take it
is asking her to be complicit
in her own abuse,
and we don't do that anymore.
But...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I don't know if people
are ready to hear that yet.
[ Ting! ]
[ Laughter ]
Then I found out
people are saying
that Prime Minister
Theresa May's Brexit strategy
means disaster for Britain.
And I was like,
"What...is that jacket?"
Where did you get it from?
I would wear the ass
off that jacket!
Would it look good on me?
Could I ask
the graphics department?
Ooh.
That's nice.
Do I dress like Theresa May?
I guess I do.
Then, something that makes
less than no sense happened.
Okay. I found out Putin
has appointed Steven Seagal
the new Russian ministry
special representative,
and I was like, "Why?!"
Which brings us to a new segment
called "Amber Says Why."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Putin, you want to improve
relations with America,
and you picked Steven Seagal?
Why?
Why did you do this,
and what exactly is
what you did?
What is it for?
Fun? Nothing? What?
Who gets something from it,
and why do they get
what they get?
And what is what they get?
Why do you?
Why did you?
Why did you do what you do?
Also, is this
the kind of thing you do,
and where is this, exactly?
Where does it take place,
and for whom?
Who can see it
when it is happening,
and who are they
and why are they that?
And what will this do?
And are you sure you want
what this will do did?
Also, do you know
who Steven Seagal is,
or, much more likely,
do you think he is someone
he is not?
Who do you think he is?
Can you see him?
When you look at him,
what do you see?
Something good?
In closing, why?
This has been "Amber Says What
& Then She Says Why."
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Give it up
for Amber Ruffin, everybody!